what is going on guys and girls welcome
to another bitcoin video in this video
i'm going to start talking about some of
the explicit and implicit
long-term prospects for bitcoin
so it is a currency or at least some
would argue that it's a commodity either
way
it's got a lot of variables to it and
many of these variables can change will
change and we'll probably even see new
ones over time also it's traded for
other currencies and those have
variables that can change as well
obviously
now the dynamic of bitcoin is really
something completely new and a lot of
you know the future plays that can
happen here haven't even been thought of
or considered so at best we can only sit
here and pontificate what the future can
bring
but that's the fun of investing
so first off we have to decide if
bitcoin is even a valid monetary system
or it can be
or at least we need to compare it to
what is considered valid money today so
let's compare it to the u.s dollar the
benefits of the us dollar is that it's
declared legally as legal tender
creditors are forced by law to accept
the us dollar's payment
interestingly enough uh businesses uh i
can't actually decline your cash money
um but they still must in the end except
dollars so they can they can turn down
your your actual physical cash but they
have to accept dollars as payment
so
um and they have done something like
this in the past good examples like
airlines who don't accept cash
but again even though they can decline
the cash
the dollars legally are and forcefully
are made as legal tender for debts goods
whatever right
so basically because the us government
says a dollar is a dollar and it's worth
you know a hundred pennies which are
worth one cent which is the value of
something that we don't even know boom
it has value right
um because there isn't anything backing
the us dollar anymore besides the fact
that we're really what backs the dollar
is is our our
our government's power and our military
power like the country's power that's
that's what does it right
um so what we say goes all right that's
that's this is a dollar
anyway
so so us dollars at least in the
investing standpoint the us dollars are
nice because they're like just declared
valuable right um
so they must be accepted by law where no
one actually has to accept bitcoin and
it's pretty unlikely in the future that
some government is going to declare by
law that you must accept bitcoin
so a lot of people rejoice in the whole
unregulated currency
uh idea reminds me a lot of like people
that just love the idea of anarchy
and people love the idea of no
government but if you have no central
authority then you have no authority
right
and we kind of begin to encroach on
nietzsche's warnings about you know
nihilism right without some sort of
central guide things can go quickly awry
and now while a lot of people
immediately just get offended at that
kind of thought it's
you know quite often seen and is
definitely occurring in culture um
especially in our culture that appears
to be definitely undergoing significant
moral decay and if if you don't agree
that you see it yourself look at your
government that you're bashing so
either way it's there
so
anyway back on track though without
government backing
uh like i say in a lot of these these
bitcoin videos it's the wild west right
with without central authority if your
money stolen nobody can help you right
if someone who only works with bitcoin
owes you money tough luck you can't
siphon that paycheck right
um accounts can't be frozen etc so
even though government's made out to be
the bad guy really often
and i can agree that there are a lot of
problems no one actually knows whether
or not the whole this bitcoin thing if
it pans out is a good idea at all to
take that kind of power away from some
sort of central authority so keep in
mind too that the the powerful people in
the world are still going to be powerful
like powerful people will be the rich
and the connected no matter what this is
still a monetary system so that's not
going to change with bitcoin if anything
the people who got a head start in
bitcoin right now
definitely not the guys you want ruling
the world we got a lot of criminals that
started with bitcoins
cash rules everything
now that said you know what does the
government do with our dollars these
days well they issue a lot of bonds
right so
so they kind of
uh issue an iou with money that they
say that they'll have in the future but
they actually don't we can see this with
our rising debt
um and you know what i get it that's
annoying right but you know moving to
uncentralized and unregulated currency
may not necessarily be the best answer
right uh it could be but how do we know
really for sure
so
the other issue with dollars is that
we're incentivized to store these
dollars with our banks so either we earn
some petty interest sometimes but mostly
the money is thought to be secure
quote-unquote in the bank
so what exactly does the bank do with
your money right well well they are
required by law to keep some of it and
this is called the fractional reserve
banking system
more on what happens with that but
basically they're only required to keep
10 ish of your money in reserves and
this can be even a lower number uh
depending
for the rest of that money they can lend
it to other people lend it to businesses
or even invest it in the stock market we
all know the uh you know adage about
gambling with money that isn't yours the
same is true here right
um so no one really pays attention to
what the banks actually do with their
money since they're all put like on the
same playing field right with fdic
insurance so every bank is basically as
safe as the other bank because of fdic
insurance so due to this
all banks are made to look equal and no
one really notices or thinks about
what's what the banks are really doing
with their money malicious or not
this means that good banks uh that are
conservative with your money and safe
are not rewarded
with more deposits let's say and bad
banks that abuse or take large risks
with your money and this country's money
are not punished
this in turn incentivizes the short term
high yield high risk plays by the banks
you wind up paying for it just like you
did starting at the end of 2007 to 2008
you're probably still paying for it and
just like the entire world did and we're
still trying to catch up
so like earlier i was talking about you
know how you know government support
of the fiat currency that we have can
help you maybe get your money but it can
also hurt you since they insure the big
banks all equally and they don't
scrutinize for bad practice
but that said besides bad practice and
say like you know phony investments in
the stock market or risky investments i
guess you can't really make phony
investments let's return back to the
fractional reserve banking system that i
was just talking about so i always
thought this was one of the more
interesting concepts that
maybe i'm wrong maybe a lot of people
have do know about this
um
but i learned i first learned about it
my senior year at uh university and the
only reason i learned about it was
because i just wanted to take an
economics course so i took a few
economics courses and this came up and
but it was just like you know a real
real short you know maybe 15 minute
discussion
and it was about the fractional reserve
banking system and what happens and it's
called the money multiplier so
what it does is just what it sounds like
with the fractional reserve banking
system
when they only have to keep 90 percent
of it yeah they could immediately just
turn
and invest that money in the stock
market and make a lot of money
but what else happens is they can lend
it out to other people and so what winds
up happening is let's just say you start
with a thousand dollars and you invest
or not invest you deposit a thousand
dollars into the bank
the bank is required to keep 100 of that
so 10 percent of that on reserve
the rest they can do whatever they want
so they could lend it to someone else
another business or another person who
then either uses it or a lot of times
when you get a loan you kind of you put
in the bank maybe for a little bit uh or
maybe you're
you're loaning or this guy's depositing
a thousand bucks a loan's 900 to this
other guy and then he you know
pays somebody for his car work the other
guy deposits that then they get loan
anyway this this happens more um it
becomes like a big uh
a big scheme that looks like a pyramid
kind of um so
so so it's not just one guy that you
know one thing that happens right so
let's say you
deposit a thousand dollars they're
required to keep a hundred they've got
it they can use 900 of that so they can
lend it to some people they can invest
some of it if they want but let's say
they just lent it to other people right
what would happen to that one thousand
dollars well one thousand dollars in the
end
gives the impression of almost ten
thousand dollars right
uh and literally just barely under nine
thousand dollars is actually floating
around in circulation so where's the
other thousand dollars well it's kept on
reserve uh but the other stuff is is
actually kind of you know being used
it's a part of the system even though we
started with a thousand dollars
now keep in mind though that each of
these people like that that money just
gets multiplied like that and continues
getting used and
this is really where
inflation comes from right because
you're just adding more money to the
system so naturally prices rise over
time and so really uh
that it's just you know i don't know
anybody you can show this to
and they just think well yeah well
that's just the way it is
that's pretty messed up and if you were
say you were investing in a business or
something and you were looking at their
accounting books and you saw their
accounting practices as being like this
are you kidding i'm pretty sure you
would like sue these guys you know
and so yeah it's it's definitely quite
the mess
so we didn't get very far in this video
and i'm sorry
uh but i did want to bring that up so
because a lot of people you know want to
say that oh you know bitcoin's a bubble
or whatnot and that's you know
bitcoin aside
uh what i hope i've established in this
video is that the monetary system that
we're currently living under
and that we you know we accept this
stuff right you work your butt off at
some job
and you get paid in this stuff so it
should be really important to you
what is happening with the value of the
stuff that you're sweating over right
and so even if you don't want to you
know think about bitcoin or you're not
sure about bitcoin still that's totally
fine but at least you should be somewhat
skeptical about the actual current
monetary system that we have
uh because it is it that's sketchy you
know like i just don't understand how
that can possibly you know be allowed so
hopefully i've taught you guys something
new uh if you want you can probably find
other videos talking about it or you can
find more information on the money
multiplier and fractional reserve
banking and what happens there's even
like calculators that you can find so
you can be like you know if i deposit a
hundred thousand dollars and we're
working with a ten percent you know
fractional reserve what what does that
become you know and you can see it you
know that's this is this is what's
happening but the sad part is
a lot of people have no idea never even
heard about fractional reserve banking
or the money multiplier right so people
aren't even kind of like aware that this
kind of thing is happening so
anyways hopefully you guys learned
something new hopefully you enjoyed the
videos
in the next video we'll be getting more
into depth about
uh bitcoin i just first kind of wanted
to talk about at least a little bit the
u.s dollar and this isn't just with the
us dollar this is with anyone that has
basically a central banking
system there you go i mean this is going
on
uh so
so keep that in mind so anyway i just
wanted to touch on the us dollar its
value its true value
um
and uh the system that we're actually
built on top of and actually if you if
you read into this system it's a system
that requires there to always be more
debt
um
than we can pay off
so
that's actually a pretty interesting
system as well i can't explain that one
too good so i'm not even going to try
there is an actual there's a pretty good
video that actually i just i saw um
pretty recently maybe i'll link it in
the description i thought it was a
pretty darn good video and it talks
about this exact thing um so yeah
anyway that's going to conclude this
video stay tuned for the next video or
we're actually talking more a little bit
more about bitcoin or at least
cryptocurrency so the next video maybe
not exactly bitcoin but then we'll start
moving into cryptocurrencies
what they bring to the table and then
soon we'll actually get into bitcoin
specifically because then we need to pin
bitcoin to decide if we actually think
bitcoin is it to the other currencies
that are out there so there's a lot of
cryptocurrencies so you have a lot of
choices so anyways hopefully you guys
are interested in that hopefully um
you've learned something new in this
video as always thanks for watching
thanks for all the support in the
subscriptions and until next time